youtube has announced that it will now
censor any videos on its platform
that suggests there was anything
irregular about the 2020 election
this show is broadcast on youtube so i
fully intend
to abide by youtube's order which means
and i just want to let you know this
right off the top so we can put it
behind us
that i can no longer mention on youtube
that georgia election officials shut
down vote counting
at 10 30 p.m on election night in
certain key areas
and then sent all the poll watchers home
and then illegally continued counting
votes almost until one in the morning i
won't be able to say that anymore
means i can no longer mention that the
pennsylvania election officials
violated their state's constitution
through the use of widespread mail-in
votes which are explicitly
unconstitutional in pennsylvania you
won't be hearing any more of that
and it means very very important i can
no longer mention
the 17 states that are joining texas's
lawsuit
against georgia pennsylvania michigan
and wisconsin over those states election
irregularities
so i guess we're just gonna have to talk
about something else i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show
[Applause]
[Music]
can't talk about it what am i supposed
to do my favorite comment yesterday from
henry knox
says biden on the aliens i mean
you got the first mainstream martian
american who is articulate
and bright and clean and nice looking
alien
i mean that's a storybook gray that is
a very incisive comment about biden
people forget this that biden who's now
considered this
liberal wonderful progressive figure
uh he he actually said that about obama
he said
you had the first nice-looking clean
articulate african-american
in barack obama and that's a storybook
he's
but he's their standard bearer now how
woke
is joe biden this youtube order is no
joke
we said yesterday that the election
lawsuits have not worked out
particularly well for president trump
there is one big one left though
there is a huge one left and this has to
go to the supreme court
in the sense that it's a state suing
other states
so before there's even the chance that
this case could be heard youtube is
saying if you
question anything about the 2020
presidential election
you'll be kicked off of youtube i don't
know if this video is going to be on
youtube right now
i'm just reading the news but the news
is contradicting youtube's
preferred political narrative so i don't
know maybe they're going to kick me off
here's the order from youtube
quote yesterday was the safe harbor
deadline for the united states
presidential election and enough states
have certified their election results
to determine a president-elect given
that
we will start removing any piece of
content uploaded today or anytime
afterward that misleads people by
alleging that widespread fraud or
errors changed the outcome of the 2020
u.s presidential election
in line with our approach toward
historical u.s
presidential elections
okay fair enough i mean not really fair
enough it's a stupid rule
but if they really held every political
candidate
to this standard at least it would be
coherent then i was remembering
a couple years ago there was a race in
georgia
for governor between brian kemp and
stacy abrams
and stacey abrams lost that race and
then she and many other people claimed
that she had won that race
and they continued to claim that after
the election was certified
and after brian kemp was sworn in in
fact that election was in 2018.
in july of last year a video was
uploaded to youtube featuring [ __ ]
uger from the young turks and some other
liberal guy describing how brian kemp
stole that election
so now uh you got unfortunately a
potential
new stolen election and that's uh
georgia
georgia absolutely so what happened is
you know in the case of uh
of georgia uh brian kemp with the help
by the way of his buddy kris kobach of
kansas
um purged um over half a million voters
the race was about a one and a half
point difference but it was actually
much
narrower than that when you looked at
what would have required a runoff yeah
it was a few thousand
bucks just a few thousand votes uh and
and they would have needed a runoff
uh yeah it was look it was a pierce deal
it was a pure steal as of the time of
this airing that video is still on
youtube there's a chance our video is
not on youtube but that video is on
youtube
seems like a double standard now you
might say michael you didn't read
carefully enough
because it says that they're going to
take down videos that question the
outcome of the presidential election
not the georgia gubernatorial election
and this is in line with their approach
historically toward u.s presidential
elections okay
okay fine so you can question the
results of other elections just not the
presidential except
except they also question the
presidential election
i i just googled very quickly for a
video that was uploaded
fairly recently trump stole 2016 will he
steal
the 2020 election this video is up on
youtube today as well
george w bush lost the lost the popular
vote by a half million votes
and his brothers and the supreme court
stole the election for him in florida
and donald trump lost the popular vote
by three million votes
and you know and frankly i think there
was some nefarious stuff going on in
ohio wisconsin pennsylvania that
that uh handed the vote to uh to donald
trump
nefarious stuff going on in ohio
wisconsin and pennsylvania in 2016
that handed the vote to donald trump
meaning nefarious right it was
wicked stuff criminal sort of stuff
illegitimate vote
so this guy some liberal guy i haven't
heard of is questioning the results of
the 2020 election and the 2000 election
in the same video but but explicitly the
2020 election
long after that election was certified
so obviously this youtube order is
complete
bs it's not a real standard there is no
historical u.s presidential election
approach and rule from youtube
they're just instituting this against
conservatives
and to defend liberals so when liberals
say that elections were stolen it's
totally fine
and when conservatives raise any
questions about ongoing litigation
that can and very likely will go to the
supreme court it's the only court that
could hear the case
you're not allowed to say that they'll
take your video down we are going to get
so so much more of this
if joe biden becomes the president
this is going to ramp up you thought big
tech censorship was bad
under trump just wait until you see what
happens if
biden becomes the president people are
really
on edge here you know just forget even
who's going to win or who's winning
these various elections
just all this uncertainty has people on
edge you know gun sales have been
spiking
if you are making a firearms purchase
because you're worried about the future
of the second amendment
i want you to be safe responsible and
carry
with a we the people holster people are
threatening your rights now on your
your first amendment rights obviously
with free speech they're threatening
your second amendment rights
too starting at just forty dollars we
the people holsters are custom designed
to fit your firearm perfectly
and they're made right here in the usa
they have thousands of options to choose
from
plus an amazing selection of printed
holsters their proprietary clip design
allows you to easily adjust your holster
so that it will fit comfortably and
securely at all
times these guys make really beautiful
high quality products lots of great
american designs go to
wethepeopleholsters.com
knowles to get yours today this has a
lifetime guarantee with it get an
additional ten dollars off
with the code knowles k wles makes a
great gift satisfaction is guaranteed
if it's not a perfect fit send it back
for a total
refund go to wethepeopleholsters.com
knowles canon wles one thing i'll tell
you especially about these guys
the price is unbelievable you're not
going to beat it anywhere and it's
excellent quality
we the peopleholsters.com slash
knowledge kwles code
knowles can a wles before they take away
your second amendment rights they're
already coming after your first
amendment rights
coming after a whole lot of rights a lot
of constitutional questions
regarding the 2020 election i'm sorry if
this
if this video turns off on youtube
halfway through i don't know i guess i
couldn't help it
but i have to read the news this is
happening right now
17 states are joining with texas
to sue georgia michigan wisconsin and
pennsylvania
over their election irregularities what
states are they
alabama arkansas florida indiana kansas
louisiana mississippi missouri montana
nebraska north dakota
oklahoma south carolina south dakota
sweet old tennessee my new home state
utah and west virginia and
president trump by the way is signing on
here as a candidate
who believes his rights were infringed
by
election irregularities and we say
irregularities we're talking about a
whole
wide range of of activities
many of which were caught on camera so
you the big tech oligarchs can't
deny that they have they can deny that
they happened but it's preposterous
they're asking us to believe them over
our own lying eyes
and in the case of pennsylvania we're
talking about a flagrant violation
of the state constitution by permitting
the use of widespread mail-in ballots
ken paxton who's the attorney general in
texas
was explaining the premise behind this
lawsuit
it's really important to my state that
my voters be represented
and if other states don't follow the
constitution
and if their state legislature isn't
responsible for
overseeing their elections and we have
other people who are not under the
constitution
under the constitution supposed to be
doing this it affects my state and so
our job is to make sure that the
constitutions follow and that every vote
counts
and in this case i'm not sure that every
vote was counted not in the right way
it is the responsibility of state
legislatures per the constitution
to set the the rules for election of
electors and in this case
those were overridden and the four
states were talking about were
overridden by other
officials whether they were judges or
other governmental officials and that's
not the way our constitution
works and that's the challenge we have
in front of the court can this be
overridden by
people who are not responsible under the
constitution for doing this
i totally agree with everything that ken
paxton just said he's a very strong
attorney general by the way and
presumably has a good political career
ahead of him
totally agree with that i i also agree
with the point that was made by arthur
bloom today
arthur bloom is a conservative writer
and editor who pointed out that
democrats
you know even in their name take
ownership of this word democracy
and they say that any attempts to to
change the
outcome of the certification is
undermining democracy
and if you go to the state legislatures
to override the unconstitutional
decisions
of say judges or of election officials
that that's somehow undermining
democracy because democracy is only what
democrats say it is
give me a break give me a break
i'm not saying that this is an ideal way
to conduct an election i'm not saying
that this
wasn't a complete debacle i think this
election was a debacle
because of corrupt election officials
and because
of misguided state legislatures and
because of partisan state supreme courts
however going to the state legislatures
and allowing a constitutional process to
play out
and having them use their legal
authority to
process and execute a presidential
election
is not undemocratic compared to
having some electors pass some new or
having some election officials rather
pass some new regulations during a
presidential election to change the way
that people vote and then having that
vote be certified
the word democratic is much broader than
than we're describing here
and frankly it's it's even sort of
secondary to the question of
the legal process established by the
constitution
all of that said i do not want to get
people's hopes up here
i said yesterday that the fat lady has
not sung yet
but you can hear her warming up you can
hear her
in the far distance clearing her throat
going up and down her scales
this lawsuit from texas is the last
stand it just is a matter of time there
isn't
time left the electors are going to vote
in a matter of days
so this is it even if there were some
magnificent other lawsuit that were
being prepared
that had heaping helpings of kraken in
it there isn't time for it anymore
and nobody's going to care how explosive
it is i keep going back to the example
of lyndon johnson who stole a 1948
senate election
and we know it with certainty as of say
1990
but okay i guess that's a moral victory
for conservatives meanwhile
johnson had already left the senate left
the vice presidency left the presidency
and died
okay we got him we got him
no he already had his effect
i don't have any confidence in the
supreme court that they will
rule properly on this case and i don't
have any confidence in the supreme court
that they'll even take it up i think the
other day
when they shot down the pennsylvania
appeal
which senator cruz was going to argue
before the court
some people are saying well they shot
that down because it would have been
redundant they were waiting for the
texas lawsuit i don't think so
i don't think so i think regardless of
what maybe they hear the case probably
they don't but
even if they do i just don't think
they're going to weigh
in on behalf of trump and on behalf of
people who feel that this election
was held in an irregular way which is
which is
incontrovertible no matter what no
matter what
youtube wants to say about it so this is
the stand i'm really pleased that texas
is doing this i'm very pleased
that uh my new state of tennessee is
doing this you know all my exes live in
texas
which is why i hang my hat in tennessee
but both states doing great work as are
those other states that are signing on
and the trump campaign
i'm glad they're doing it i hope we can
fight extraordinarily hard
and if it doesn't work out we're all
going to make sure that we have a lot to
drink which is why i've got to tell you
about first leaf the
there is nothing like that friday
feeling you know
but i don't need to wait for that
feeling to kick in once a week because
with award-winning wine from first leaf
any day can feel like friday first leaf
is a wine club
that sends personalized selections of
wine from top vineyards around the world
directly to you
because the only thing better than one
fantastic bottle wine is a case of
award-winning wine that shows up at your
doorstep
every bottle is hand-picked by experts
with your exact preferences and palate
in mind how do they know that because
they send you wines based on your
preferences
but they'll mix it up sometimes a little
push your boundaries and then
if you really like you you rate them and
then as you use first leaf
they get more and more in tune to your
tastes i've been a
member of other wine clubs and all those
other wine clubs are terrible in my
experience
first leaf is excellent they gave me a
freebie for my first shipment and it was
so great
that i now have the highest tier of
membership
i love it i use it all the time
subscriptions are flexible
and shipments arrive on your schedule
with practically zero effort
plus first leaf is much more affordable
uh and and much easier
to to get wine from top wine makers and
vineyards check it out right now what
are you waiting for
get that friday feeling like i do any
day with first leaf join today and you
will get six bottles of wine
for 29.95 and free shipping that's an
unbelievable deal first of all
even i i always say the first leaf
membership is the best money i spend
every month but
you can get it 29.95 and free shipping
go to tryfirstleaf.com
knowles that's six bottles of wine for
29.95 free shipping at tryfirstleaf.com
knowles
if the courts do not go the right way
if joe biden becomes president is named
president-elect
there is still a lot that we can do in
the meantime you saw a little bit
of this happening yesterday there are
things we can do with the doj there are
things we can do with the executive
agencies
there are things that we can do as a
matter of executive orders
so this came out of the u.s attorney's
office
just yesterday federal law enforcement
officials
are investigating hunter biden for all
sorts of tax related
matters shady business deals that sort
of thing there had
been an investigation already into
hunter biden that was going on
because hunter biden obviously has been
peddling his father's influence
for years and years now enriching
himself to the tune of millions and
millions of dollars
joe biden knew about this we have the
hunter biden laptop joe biden
was aware of this hunter button admitted
it himself that he talked to his dad
about these business deals
and so joe denies it but we have his son
contradicting him
about it he made a lot of money on this
there was an investigation there
actually was an investigation even
before bill barr took over at the doj
they paused this for the presidential
election because they didn't want it to
be seen as any sort of impropriety
interfering in the election now that has
picked up again
this is very important not because
they're going to nab
hunter biden i don't think they will i
don't think joe biden if he becomes
president will allow them
to nab hunter biden even though it's so
the corruption is so preposterous
unless hunter biden is some expert in
chinese financial affairs and an expert
in ukrainian
energy companies obviously this was pure
corruption you had that that
ccp expert yesterday admitting that they
bought off the biden family in china
however the reason it's important is
because if joe biden becomes president
then he's going to have to be the one to
shut down this investigation
and that's not going to look right he's
going to have to go in there and expose
his own corruption
or allow the investigation to proceed
which
very likely would implicate him as well
that's one thing we can do
i think we need to keep that up we need
to
ramp that up ramp up as many
investigations that are as hard to shut
down
as possible definitely do that another
thing we need to do if joe biden is
going to become president
which he he may the supreme court has
suggested that he
he very likely will get eric swalwell
kicked off of the house intelligence
committee
and possibly get him kicked out of
congress we talked yesterday about
swalwell's honey trap the idea that
swalwell was close with this chinese spy
she seems to have raised a lot of money
for him may have raised
uh many things while she was in the
country we don't know
okay we know it seems as though the fbi
believes
that this chinese spy slept with
multiple u.s officials was it eric
swalwell we don't know if she did sleep
with eric swalwell because eric swalwell
is
us according to his 2020 presidential
campaign that means that we all slept
with eric swalwell which means we all
cheated on our wives except that means
our wives slept with her too
which means we're all in the same boat
more details are coming out about this
it's going to be very embarrassing for
mr swalwell
it's especially embarrassing because the
rank hypocrisy here
during the 2016 campaign and the
aftermath of that
eric swalwell in many ways led the
charge
accusing don jr of one
time meeting with someone who might have
been associated with the russian
government
i think we've all gotten a phd in
russian studies that none of us
signed up for but
stated plainly the president's son met
with
a russian spy we now have the best
evidence of that
in our minority report the democrats put
out that ms veselnitskaya
was going all over the world and bumping
into dana rohrabacher which is a sign of
a spy someone who tries to create you
know a coincidence
encounter and now we know that she was
working at the behest
of the russian government the
president's son nicole met with a
russian spy
so the president's son may have met with
a someone who connected to the russian
government
but eric swalwell would appear did a
whole lot more than bump into
chinese spies well but it depends on how
we look at that verb
eric swalwell appears to have had a much
more intimate relationship
with a chinese spy china a much more
threatening adversary to the united
states
than russia
this man cannot be permitted to stay on
the house intel committee i don't know
they're not going to get him kicked out
of congress but it is absolutely
insane that this man is allowed to
remain on the house intel committee he
absolutely has to be stripped of that
republicans should keep beating that
drum why who cares about eric swalwell
because it's the right thing to do it
exposes the impropriety this story about
the chinese spy and eric swalwell
is absolutely going to be covered up by
the mainstream media no one's going to
talk about it other than us
we need to turn up as much pressure as
we possibly can to get that dude
kicked off of the intel committee one
because he's a national security risk
and a blackmail risk
but two because we need to
expose the story as a as a political
matter as well it's a national security
matter
it's also a matter of simple politics if
the media aren't going to expose the
story we need to keep it up we're the
only ones
who can do that you know we are
it feels as though we're on a razor's
edge in this country of
of turning into a a very bad direction
with regard to china with regard to
domestic politics
we're right on that razor's edge it's a
very very sharp edge but it's not as
sharp as harry's razors
harry's just came out with their
sharpest blades ever and unlike some
other
razor companies they are not charging
you more for their product improvements
i shaved with a harry's razor today and
it's the greatest harry's it's
not it's also the greatest terry's razor
i've ever used but it's the greatest
razor
period harry's new sharper blades are
still as low as two
dollars each other razor companies have
increased their prices
when they introduced something new
harry's is delivering their sharpest
shave ever
and they aren't raising their prices i
got to tell you you know i just moved
recently
and what's great about harry is you can
get the razors shipped to you so it's
all very easy but when you move
sometimes you forget to change the
address and everything
so i found myself i was using the same
hairy's blade
for a long long long time and it still
remained extraordinarily sharp
now though i have bought a lot more
hairs razor blades it's wonderful they
have 100 quality guarantee at harris.com
really great stuff simple very high
quality
harry's is available wherever you shop
you can get harry's sharpest blades
ever at big box drug in grocery stores
near you you head on over to the
grooming aisle
and if you like to shop online which i
do harry's has a great offer for
listeners
new us customers can redeem a harry's
trial set at harrys.com
slash knowles cannonwles you'll get a
five blade razor featuring their new
sharper blades a weighted handle foaming
shave gel with aloe and a travel cover
which i really really like that's a nice
innovation to protect your blade
wherever you're on the go just go to
harrys.com
knowles and redeem your trial offer
today
we should get it as tough as possible on
these democrats
as a political matter if it looks like
the election is really going to biden
because the democrats are going to
be merciless when it comes to us they're
not just going to get tough in a
political way they're going to get tough
in a physical way they're they're
threatening republicans all over you
hear joe biden every so often
say we need healing we need unity barack
obama is the first articulate black man
in america he said he said that
he did say that don't forget that he
said that the woke people are going to
try to erase that but he did
the democrats are going to be merciless
well well joe biden is telling us
that we're going to have unity and
healing you have a michigan state
representative
cynthia johnson threatening trump
supporters and telling her constituents
to go after them
so this is just a warning to you
trumpers
be careful walk lightly
we ain't playing with you enough
of the shenanigans
enough is enough
and for those of you who are soldiers
you know how to do it do it right
be in order make them pay
i love you bye-bye
i don't think she loves us
of all i believe most of what she just
said
the one thing i don't believe is that
she loves us all i think she wants to
kill
trump supporters she's calling
to kill us she's not saying
be mean to them or even maxine waters
said you know
find them where they are in public and
go to their homes and yell at them and
push back on them
this woman is calling on people to
murder us
she says you know you know trumpers you
better watch out you better watch out
and even then you say okay maybe it's
just a sort of
vague threat and she goes those of you
who are soldiers
you know what to do you know how to do
it well what do
soldiers kill people right that's what
they do
soldiers kill people and this elected
democrat wants to kill
us she has been stripped of her
committee assignments
and may face further disciplinary action
apparently according to the michigan
house
representative lee chatfield ain't good
enough
buddy not even close to good obviously
she's stripped of her committee
assignments
she certainly should be kicked out of
the michigan state house
i don't know maybe she should face some
criminal charges
you're not allowed to threaten to kill
people
that's a that's a big deal and she's
threatening to kill
all the trump supporters and she's
inciting soldiers to kill us she's
asking the soldiers to kill us
ain't good enough ain't good enough to
strip her of her committee assignments
at the very least she needs to be kicked
out of the the state house
and probably she should face criminal
charges
we're going to get a whole lot more of
that we're not going to be able to speak
out against it because big tech has
already told us
they're not going to let us voice our
opinions they say if you have any
problem with the 2020 election
and you've got any problem with that go
somewhere else
build your own youtube that's what they
say that's you'd hear this from the kind
of
squishy republicans that say well just
we can't we can't make youtube do what
we want
through politics so we just build your
own youtube you can't build your own
youtube
you can't build your own youtube they
have taken over the market
they have a critical mass they acquire
that critical mass through fraud
and through the exploitation of
legal uh liability protections that they
do not deserve
and we need to get a little bit tougher
than we used to be as republicans i
don't mean tougher in the way that she
says go kill all the
your political opponents i mean get
tougher through politics
through the law and unbelievable this is
this is the funniest headline i've read
probably in weeks during this whole
period the washington post
believes that republicans need to
nominate possibly the most liberal
member of their party
to the 2020 republican nomination
we'll get into that very very silly
article you know
there are some bright sides to 2020.
it's been a tough year
in many many ways there are some bright
sides one of them is the new and
improved leftist tears tumbler you can
keep those leftist tears hot or cold
in a new stainless steel design with a
custom daily wire
lid all dishwasher safe very very snazzy
join daily wire now or upgrade your
membership to get yours just in time
to enjoy those salty tears while
watching all of our new content
the michael knowles show is now five
days a week how great is that by the way
we're also going to radio in january
that's gonna be a lot of fun by the way
we also got the prageru catalog at
dailywire.com
which includes one of my shows the
prageru book club also includes
candace owen's show and by the way
candace is coming to the daily wire
there's so much great stuff coming on
it's going to be a whole lot of fun by
the way we've got our first feature film
coming out under daily wire's upcoming
entertainment channel
we're building a new investigative
journalism team to replace the legacy
media cartel
go outside the narrative come on over to
dailywire.com subscribe we are loud
we are opinionated we're having a very
good time we'll be right back with a lot
more
elected democrats are threatening to
kill us
and the largest media companies in the
world
are threatening to censor us promising
to censor us
you've got a major political realignment
going on even even the new york times
admitted this yesterday the new york
times said
that joe biden joe from scranton didn't
win the working class
right they always said joe was going to
win back the working class and he was
going to win back
you know black and latino voters and
actually what you saw in 2016
and as much as you take the election
results at face value
is trump actually made inroads he made
gains among the working class
among black voters among hispanic voters
among
everybody apparently except for white
men and
if you look at education that was the
big difference the
the people who have more college degrees
which by the way i will not confuse with
actual education
but the people who have more of these
educational credentials
are more likely to vote for democrats
the people who have less of those
educational credentials more likely to
vote for republicans
which completely blows up the former
democratic idea
that republicans were the class of the
rich and the plutocrats and rich uncle
pennybags
no the republicans are
a diverse party but inasmuch as the
working class has a party
it's the republican party and even the
new york times is admitting this now
so while you've got this major political
realignment
the swamp blob liberal
establishment wants to go back to
business as usual wants to go back to
the old way of doing things
wants to go back to nominating squishes
for the republican party who can then
lose with dignity
dignity to the democratic candidate
from the washington post the silliest
column i've read in quite some time
or i guess it's not even a column i
guess a news article
i haven't abandoned my principles larry
hogan
pondering challenge to trump casts
himself
as a traditional republican now this
this article came out last year
this is being promoted in the past few
days
the larry hogan presidency presidential
campaign
as the future of the republican party
this is what they wrote
maryland governor larry hogan
acknowledges that many republicans
nationwide who have heard about his
potential presidential ambitions
probably view him as a centrist with
little hope
of finding support in trump's gop but
amid growing tensions between trump and
republican lawmakers over
foreign policy and the president's
treatment of global alliances hogan is
signaling that if he decides to wage an
insurgent campaign
he would pitch himself as far more in
tune with the party's long-held values
and worldview
than trump i come from the ronald reagan
school of politics
hogan said last week in a wide-ranging
interview at the state capitol
shaking his head in disapproval when
asked whether he shares trump's
nationalism
then he talks about how great the old
sort of
post-war liberal consensus was and talks
about how great liberal republicans are
and pretends that he's ronald reagan
because he's a liberal
when larry hogan said the only reason i
bring up this older article right now
is because hogan 2024 is now getting a
surge on social media
from blue checkmark liberals who are
completely out of touch with the gop
base
when larry hogan says he's never
abandoned his principles i actually take
him at face value
he's always been a liberal republican
and he is still a liberal republican his
values are liberal values
he has mitt romney i don't think has
abandoned his values
his values were always to be a slick
liberal politician
who would occasionally lie and pretend
to be more conservative than he is when
he thought it would benefit his
political career
and there are a lot of republicans like
that
when he says i come from the ronald
reagan school of politics you are going
to hear this not
you've been hearing it for years from
the washington post you're hearing it
today
this canard that back in reagan's day
you know reagan whom
the liberal establishment loved oh they
loved him
after he died they loved him when he was
alive they hated his guts called him a
nazi called him
kkk he said all of his supporters were
nazis and white supremacists same thing
they did to trump they said ronald
reagan you know at least he could get
along with democrats
he would he and tip o'neill who was the
speaker of the house
they would fight all day long but you
know at six o'clock they'd go over
they'd have drinks together they were
friends
the only problem with that story is that
it's completely untrue nothing about
that is true
they hated one another they were not
friends they did not work together
i would be surprised if they ever had
more than a drink together
tip o'neill called ronald reagan evil
he said that he had ice water running
through his veins
reagan was a little bit nicer to tip
o'neill in public
than tip o'neill was to ronald reagan
but in private these guys
absolutely hated one another they didn't
spend time together they didn't chat and
they didn't work on anything together
we have to oppose the liberal left
we don't want to become the liberal left
what the establishment wants us to do is
nominate the mitt romneys and the john
mccains
and the larry hogans and the john
kasichs and all those guys
jeff flake and put them up as pretend
opposition court jester conservatives
who can go up there and
if they win it's not a big deal because
they're liberals and really they're
probably going to lose and it's good if
they lose because they've played their
part
in this kingdom of liberalism they want
to put up republicans who agree with the
left on basically every cultural matter
but maybe they disagree on tax cuts or
something but actually here's the secret
here's the big secret the liberal
establishment doesn't mind tax cuts
actually the most of the richest people
in the country are extremely wealthy and
they enjoy tax cuts
and the tax cuts don't threaten their
social programs because they just borrow
more money from china to fund them
and they're going to cozy up to china if
joe biden becomes president
not enough those guys weak sauce that's
preposterous because they would never
get through a gop nomination
not not these days we need to get
cultural you know we talked about this
issue that keeps coming up
the porn issue the porn debate i know
some people don't like the porn debate
i think the porn debate is important in
itself it's also important though
even if you don't care about the porn
thing it's important as a symbol of
digging in on cultural matters
because the culture will affect politics
politics will affect culture too but the
culture will affect the politics
so there's a big problem with with
online pornography
nicholas kristof the liberal columnist
in the new york times came out and he
said look there's
child pornography on here or under at
least under a they might not be five
years old but they're at least
17 years old 15 years old 14 years old
that's obviously illegal
and there's rape victims trafficking
victims and so you got to get this off
here
the only reason this got any play is
because you had someone working from
within the liberal establishment who
called this out he wasn't calling out
the other problems with porn namely that
it gets young boys addicted at a very
young age and perverts the entire
country and
turns us all into just sort of over
sensitized vicious people licentious
people who aren't
capable of liberty that's the more
conservative critique of
porn but the liberal critique is well
consent you know and all these sorts of
problems okay
as a result of that credit card
companies suggested they were going to
cut off pornhub so
mastercard and visa came out publicly so
they were reconsidering their
relationship with pornhub
after kristoff accused the side of being
infested with
not just the underage stuff but racist
violent misogynistic content uh then
the the companies came out and said
we're not going to do business with them
that's very good we can cheer that on
we can cheer that on as conservatives we
need to take the victories that we can
get even if it is aided by
liberals through liberal establishments
even through some arguments that are
maybe secondary to the broader argument
you know the idea that there's
racism on pornhu i don't even really
know what that means to say there's
racism on pornhub
to me the bigger issue is the fact that
we're getting
young boys hooked on all this licentious
stuff and that there's exploitative
content on there but
fine okay it's a through racism okay
fine whatever works
to weaken that giant company's
exploitative hold on the culture
that's great that's good stuff
you could imagine that some real pure
free marketeers would say this is a
distortion of the free market
you should not allow these kind of
cultural factors to come into play you
should not allow
certainly you shouldn't allow government
to threaten pornhub's ability to do
whatever they want
even though we've had obscenity laws in
this country from the very beginning but
even
you know even the idea that you're not
going to allow people to use certain
payment processors
i don't know it's a little dicey i guess
the payment processors are their own
companies but still these are market
interferences
pornhub has no right to exist
has no right to exist according to the
constitution there's no right according
to us law there's no right
our founding fathers would be rolling
over in their graves if they knew that
this sort of thing were happening
now i'm not saying that means we need to
outright ban pornhub
right away because i i actually don't
think it's possible
politically i don't know that it's
prudent we we went through some of the
arguments from saint augustine and saint
thomas aquinas
over why they defended legal
prostitution and
some space in politics
to recognize that these vices won't be
totally suppressed the idea that you're
not going to
cut out lust from the heart of man
eternally you need to be prudent you
need to be wise as a serpent
and innocent as a dove but let's not
just give pornhub a free pass
absolutely not keep the pressure up
let's not pretend they have any right to
exist
they exist because
at the pleasure of the american people
you can interpret pleasure however you
like
they have no right to exist though and
by the way the the thing worked
to some degree pornhub says that now
they're only going to
have content partners and people within
their model program
be able to upload content to pornhub
meaning that you know they're going to
have some kind of way of verifying who
gets to upload content
they're not going to allow users to
download content from pornhub
with the exception of paid downloads
from the verified model program
okay they've got fingerprinting
technology which will mitigate the
ability for
content that's already been removed to
be re-uploaded that's going to be
effective immediately they're also going
to establish a red
team to self-audit the platform for
potentially illegal material so that
means someone's job is just to sit all
day
and look at the most heinous kind of
pornography probably illegal pornography
and take it down doesn't sound like
great work sounds like pretty corrupting
work but
anyway they're going to do that i don't
know that we can trust pornhub to do it
that's a good start
glad that they're doing that but it's
not enough my proposal for pornhub
is if you want to use pornhub not just
upload content but if you want to use it
if you want to access it
you've got to upload a valid id
doesn't matter how old you are you could
be 65 years old if you want to use
pornhub if you want to access it and
download it
you need to upload an id the reason for
this is in part age verification and
import shame
it's the same reason that you have to
show an id when you go buy a playboy
right it's the same reason the playboy
when you go buy it at the store is in a
different kind of section of the store a
different kind of envelope or something
because there should be some shame here
we should cultivate that shame there's
nothing wrong with doing that
people ought to feel that shame
themselves and i'm not
still people a lot of people are going
to use it something like
approximately 100 of men have looked at
online pornography at some point
the joke about the survey is that what
was it 94 of men have looked at
naked ladies on the internet and six
percent of men are lying there's
something to that effect so it's a good
start
and as conservatives what you want to do
is fix the problem in the way that you
can you're not
going for a total revolutionary solution
right away you're not
going to let the perfect get in the way
of the good but this is a somewhat
decent story
we need good standards again you know
right now we pretend that we don't have
standards
we pretend that anything goes because
you hear things like oh if it feels good
do it love is love it's
if it doesn't hurt anybody you know it's
your choice man whatever but we we do
have standards actually
the the standards are political
correctness and the problem is those
standards are dumb
and bad but we have them we just need
good standards
is the issue a kumail johnny
who is apparently an actor he has a blue
check mark on twitter and i'm reliably
informed he's an actor
kumail says he tweeted this out
yesterday
traditional masculinity is a disease
and when i read that when i saw this
ostensible
ostensibly a man tweeting out
traditional masculinity as
a disease i just thought i hope she sees
this bro whatever feminist girl you're
trying to impress with that tweet i hope
she sees it
i hope it was worth something this is
what they say when they say
on the left that masculinity is toxic or
something
um they're not referring to a specific
kind of toxic masculinity but they like
the good masculinity they hate the toxic
one
i actually think that would be an
interesting conversation to have because
there are aspects of
the heart of man that is not great you
know and that we should
correct through virtue but that's not
what they're saying what they really
believe is that all masculinity
traditional masculinity is a disease
and the alternative to that i suspect is
femininity
but that's not true when a woman acts
like a woman she's womanly and that's a
good thing when a man
acts like a man he's manly that's a good
thing when a man acts like a woman he's
not womanly he's womanish that's why we
have two words for that
because there's something disordered
about that there's something very wrong
about that it's not that
womanliness there's anything wrong with
that it's not that there's anything
wrong with femininity
it's that there's something wrong when
men behave in a womanish
way and vice versa because there are
standards
there used to be standards and what
political correctness wants to do is
invert those standards
so the idea of feminism was to
apply traditionally male values and make
all women live up to that
simone de bouvoir very famous feminist
and jean-paul sartre's trumpet
famously said to betty friedan another
very famous feminist
that women cannot be given the choice to
stay home and raise kids because if
given that choice they'll take it
and that's bad they need to go out and
work they need to adopt male values
so that so what political greatness does
is insist that women become men
and as kumail najani says men need to
become women
that's a very bad idea i think i know
this is a radical proposal men should be
men and women should be women
but in order to have that standard which
was once considered common sense for
you know all of human history until five
minutes ago for that standard
to come back we need to articulate it we
can't just throw up our hands and say
you do you and anybody does anything and
i don't care how you behave and it
doesn't affect me no you you have to be
a little stronger than that
you have to go out and say men should do
this
men should act with chivalry which is by
the way another standard
it's not the left calls that identity
politics it's not
real identity politics is a specific
thing it's a left-wing modern
invention chivalry is a different kind
of standard that's the one
we should go for we need clarity on
these things we need clarity on our
friends and our enemies
this is a huge news story documents
revealed
on wednesday by canada's
rebel news network ezra lavon
show that canada was planning to train
chinese
soldiers in cold weather tactics
at a military base in ontario and they
canceled that program reluctantly
when the white house found out about it
and asked them to cancel it
canada was going to invite america's
number one
enemy in the world to our doorstep
to train their military
justin trudeau obviously making his
father
very proud here you can interpret that
statement as you will
as well if you're unfamiliar with this
question
feel free to google justin trudeau's
father it's very interesting
very interesting reading but i'm sure
i'm sure he's making
whatever you discover on that little
journey down the internet
uh either way he would be making his
father very very proud this is some
radical
stuff and it's happening very quickly
drew clavin likes to use this line that
he's taking from
ernest hemingway that then i've stolen
from both of those guys which is
things happen gradually then suddenly
this election has been happening
gradually and gradually gradually
now we're approaching the suddenly part
we're days away from the electors voting
the supreme court not signaling that
they're going to be too
helpful to the trump campaign in the
trump legal effort
so we we might be getting into the
suddenly part of all of this
and suddenly it's going to look really
really bad from big tech
from elected republicans on domestic
policy
from the culture cultural standpoint and
from
the foreign policy standpoint we need to
be extraordinarily vigilant
we need to do everything we possibly can
if this election is not going to go for
trump
we need to do everything we possibly can
while we still have the power i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. hey
everybody it's andrew clavin host of the
andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton